okay for people who are joining this
livestream we are talking about features
of future versions of often language not
12-point Oh for those who paying
attention this is about temporal logic
and so let us start off with the there's
gonna be a giant motivation section Oh
what is temporal logic yes okay
propositions qualified in terms of time
yes well it's great
in principle I am always hungry I will
eventually be hungry except that we
can't yet formulate the concept of being
hungry in our language but so what's an
example of something we would for
example this condition will always be
true this condition will eventually be
true those kinds of things right well as
I gonna enter the example you could say
something like the population France has
always been greater than a million will
eventually be whatever yeah okay so okay
versions in philosophy and math Michael
logic okay offer prior indeed and he
wasn't even the person after whom
Bayesian pyres were named sorry I'm just
joking okay linear temporal logic is
equivalent to magnetic first-order logic
okay um okay we have an immediate
question on the live stream from Brian
asking if this will support Leslie
Lamport
temporal logic of actions Yann do you
know the relationship I it Leslie
Lamport I remember I've run into him
he's talked about temporal logic but I
don't know do you know what he's done on
what he did on that uh no not really I
haven't been exploring temporal logic of
actions at all have you heard of that no
not really I will have a look into it
after the meeting though okay um I
remember lesson
port tell me about the stuff at some
point and um who knows maybe it's built
until a tech I'm joke just joking
um okay monadic first-order logic okay
why is it relevant to tree-like
structures why is it relevant to
describing tree-like structures
I can see one-dimensional sequences but
I don't understand the tree like climb
of course
so the tree-like structures are come
into play when we discuss different
different nonlinear models of time so
instead of thinking about what future
you think about all possible futures in
fun and think about time branching this
way okay all right phone verification
yes okay all right yeah yeah yeah
Pentium bug I don't know whether it's
that they're using a bunch of
verification I have no idea with a
temporal logic there was a there's a
thing there's a British company which
had this thing see something or other
see gosh I remember that was was crowing
a lots around the time of the Pentium
bug that they had some formally verified
something but I don't think they were
talking about you and I don't think they
were using temporal logic um do we know
Roger German s'en his PhD thesis was
about some kind of verification do we
know if it was you know if we use
temporal logic anybody know yes I've
talked to him about this and he he just
a version based on on relations and as
recreations and and how does that fit
into this collection of things that
you're describing
we will see later I think he uses the
CTL version of temporal logic not the
little T on the CTL and he has special
way of specifying the models but yes
let's start first distinguishing antia
from Cydia okay you gotta be kidding me
about the introducing these to improve
readability well anyway I think the
words will include readability anything
that involves a random diamond shine up
in the middle of something it's not
going to help anything is that with was
the formulas tend to be extremely
lengthy so sometimes it's easier to have
something very compact I will say okay
all right so you can always just have
it's the dead of the make boxes you know
looks like that
it doesn't need to I mean I didn't need
to actually be that problem but I don't
think it's gonna help I think I think
the words I mean it could be that the
functional form isn't the best behavior
we're getting ahead of ourselves look
that's just okay so this is linear
temporal logic okay true in the next
moment of time okay and so Nick is here
right who's gonna be able to see how
this relates to our date formalism so
true okay all right so always eventually
be okay so that means and by the way how
does this relate to pause on graphs
which are obviously illustrating here so
sorry what was the question
exactly no I'm I didn't think I have a
very good question
can we see an example okay so hold on so
then always so
so I think we're going a bit too fast
let's go back a bit and so these these
operators are in all the literature
about these and there are two parts the
first one is kind of trivial then they
have we have the first pair all and some
which is a bit like for all and exists
so this this form a pair and then there
is the other one the other two also
forming some sort of term and there are
this type of relation saying you can't
use all of them from two and things like
that but these are the five operators
that are used in literature so illness
so what is next moment of my main
version yes so the model of time that we
are assuming here is distributed
discrete model so we have a discrete
sequence of moments and next moment Phi
basically means that in the next moment
Phi is going to be true at each moment
we have a certain set of propositions
that are true at this moment okay and
for example this small sequence that we
have in the semantic sections it
illustrates a temporal formula like
eventually always see together with a
model of this formula so C in this case
is a logical proposition and a model for
for any formula is a sequence with
propositions assigned to basically each
index of the sequence and here we can
see that at the initial at the starting
time propositions a and B are true then
they become false and then proposition C
is true forever from that point and that
sequence of that data and basically that
sequence of worlds because we talked
about all these points at time we refer
to them as worlds so this sequence of
worlds is a model for eventually always
C okay I understand
I think I have to get a little bit more
I haven't kind of seen the point yet I
mean in other words what what's an
example of a temple logic simplification
that you can do that's non-trivial of
something where you yeah mm-hmm I think
we're gonna get to more interesting
examples as we go to a few improving
section which is in using temporal logic
in Wolfram language okay so far it's
more introducing syntax and semantics of
logic all right so a formula will be it
next moment at the next moment a implies
B and at the next moment a and not and
not B yes that's what I put all of these
things inside the next moment why can't
I say next moment of a implies B and a
and not B you can that would be
equivalent that's we could prove this
later okay what does SNF mean that's a
normal so it's exactly it's a separated
normal form it's a particular normal
form that's used a lot in linear
temporal logic okay so okay what does
the implies well alright okay I think we
should go on because I don't I don't yet
really get the points here I'm like to
see some more real examples but let's so
let's just skip forward let's look
through this a bit okay computational
tree logic oh my gosh okay
so I think if we want to see examples we
should go to a using temporal logic you
will from language because first I just
introduced the syntax for the
corresponding logics and explain the
basic semantics there there are really
no non-trivial examples in this section
okay all right okay fine so always I
so this is an assertion what would be an
analogous thing wait a minute an
assertion normally if you just say P and
Q mmhmm I see that might be true it
might not be true it depends on the
state of the world and what P and Q
happen to be uh huh okay
always what what's the one way it's some
arbitrary predicate right correct
um I think that we will interesting I
would suggest to go to the section for
improving and maybe first we can look at
simple examples in fear improving
because these examples here are more to
just illustrate how this looks like in
Wolfram language not really to provide
something non-trivial and interesting
crap okay temporal tautology Q not
always P is the same as eventually not P
yes that's true so of course these are
quite simple statements but here we are
able to verify them automatically and
one use of being able to verify
automatically these kinds of statements
is we can use temporal logic to specify
the properties of some systems that we
care about and then we can use it to
specify some requirements about the
systems that we care about and then we
want to prove that the temporal formula
which specifies the requirements is
implied by temporal formula that
specifies the our system the behavior of
our system okay let's let's try and read
this one here this dot implies lives
what is that what is the start of thing
is that a special symbol or is that just
something yes so start is a special
symbol which is true at the beginning of
time so we always assume that time
starts at some point so like we switch
on our system and that's the only that
start is something that's true like the
minus infinity on the number
or something something like this a
quorum so what a start implies lives so
it means that some is that lives is true
at the start so if you're thinking about
this sequence of moments and there is a
first moment it's better to think about
this as a natural number so why is it
like is true at or is true at time or
something like that I mean I think could
do that but it's just that you can also
easily encode it with it implies yes now
I don't understand that this isn't a
priming the thing about implies is
you're expecting a proposition and
implies it is a proposition it says that
start is true then lives is also true
right and start is true at the very
first moment so it's saying if you're in
the very first moment then mix is true
right okay so but but from our point of
view of language design the symbol start
isn't really doesn't I mean are you
claiming that the symbols start is sort
of analogous to a symbol like true yes
and it's very very standard in temporal
logic don't care I mean it's not going
to help you know we're not going to be
able to have a symbol called start can
happen so well um
starting moment but even that doesn't
seem right because it's a predicate not
a predicate it's a proposition and
Siddhanta moment doesn't sound like a
proposition I mean yeah eventually we
should be able to adhere the actual
dates so people who just used a date or
something that's then it's totally weird
to have you know look what would be the
rapper assuming there was a date here
and something implies lives
isn't it so is is currently is that time
and then or is such-and-such a time and
then a date is that what it is what's
the actual proposition that's going to
imply lives to go what I'm asking
yes sir the proposition is we are at the
beginning of time not okay but we are at
a given time so yes um so it's like is
is that time that's very badly said but
that's that's roughly what it is at a
time and then this could be lost
Saturday and then this could then be
saying you know lost Saturday um the um
[Music]
um ah let's see um you know that that
will be a specific date lost Saturday or
something
um okay let me try and understand the
rest of this okay so is it that is that
that date implies lives and lives
implies not dead and what oh I see if
dead the next moment of dead if you're
dead you're still there and if lives
implies eventually dead okay
okay so that's
coding its encoding the fact that you
know in a state transition diagram you
would go from the live state to the dead
state eventually so what is the analogy
what is the analog of like state
transition diagrams versus these kinds
of logic statements there are very
closely related in fact state transition
diagrams can be also models for this
this formulas and we say well basically
for any state transition diagram we can
ask about for any formula we can
correspond a steady state transition
diagram okay they are actually in
bi-directionally of each other and on
the other hand we can ask whether a
property holds over a state transition
diagram which is exactly the point of
model checking which is short later in
the in the presentation okay okay so
here we are just showing some very very
simple theorem proving capability
capabilities boy I mean is it the case
when people really use this stuff are
they really gonna use temporal logic or
are they gonna use state transition
diagrams I think that what they do a lot
is they use they do model tracking I
think that's the main use case in the
industry and this is mainly state
transition diagram as a model of their
system and then there's a temporal logic
formula as there are requirements about
the system so the use kind of
combination of both for the system to
model it the use state transition
diagram and then they have some
something that they want from this
system and that's more convenience to
modeling in logic okay so let's
understand it now okay okay so then
another
as petri nets I'd like to understand do
you understand the relationship of this
to those guys and now that's really okay
I mean my question is okay so let's
let's talk about some very mundane
things about us like recurring events
represented in does this help with
representing recurring events I I think
it does we could say for example that
some event happens that always
eventually something happens so it means
that it will happen infinitely many
times in the future yeah yes I think
Stephen is thinking about how did you
specify every Wednesday something like
that so I don't think okay so that's a
this level or can you say something like
like I mean you could just say if the
date today is Wednesday that implies
something right yes and also well I
haven't really dived into this yet but
there are more complicated versions of
temporal logic basically temporal logic
isn't a bit of an umbrella term for many
different formal languages and there are
varieties of temporal logic called
times temporal logic which are more
exotic but they are designed to tackle
these kinds of problems I refer to
particular intervals between events and
so on so so I mean one of the reasons we
got into the temporal logic business in
the first place is because we imagined
that there are you know practical
applications of this stuff that um that
um you know a somewhat low-hanging fruit
just like you could say well we can
implement you know propositional logic
and we could do that as a formal matter
just for the sake of having
propositional logic but it's super
useful to be able to say if a and B blah
blah blah I'm making sense of the
question is for this the sort of
everyday uses of this not for the sake
of doing things specifically in temporal
logic I'm trying to understand what
those are in our system now clearly one
thing is assertions of various kinds
mm-hmm
we can imagine you know always well as
you have them here you know always X
greater than four or something which is
very similar to assert X greater than
four but it has a slightly different
character because it's a it's something
where you'd say given IC so given this
program well in fact this is exactly the
example you're now showing here I don't
understand this I mean so so for this
you have to have multiple levels of
stuff going on you have to have a
symbolic representation for the code and
then you're basically proving an
assertion relative to that symbolic
representation right so but since we
don't have a symbolic representation at
the level well I mean we do but it isn't
there go ahead so yeah yeah what's
happening here is you're having a code
and we can construct a function that
basically takes a rockhole and that
produces a temporal formula that
describes the behavior of this code and
then what we want to do is we want to
prove certain properties from this
temporal formula
and this properties has to be specified
well you're never realistically gonna be
able to do this for any serious program
ah
well of course there are all kinds of
problems with will be good we will be I
mean is it is it is this a toy or is
this something which is actually gonna
be useful I mean I'm trying to
understand okay so the reason we got
into this is because well let me just
try to understand so so Nick for example
was working on recurring events right
and being able to say things like this
happens every Wednesday since the
beginning of time well this happens
every Wednesday since you know January
of 1990 okay so I mean roughly we then
have certain temporal specifications I
mean it let's let's imagine that we say
um you know don't know do you have Nick
do you have yet a representation of the
recurring event let's say do you have
any representations of these recurring
events we don't I mean we have a general
day I think it's still in the repository
I think there's a future eyes rest page
for date select okay encouragingly Brian
on our live stream is saying this is
useful mm-hmm yeah I mean there is there
from what I've looked at there is some
crossover between like scheduling
problems and temporal logic but it tends
to be a little more restricted you know
there may be you know it's it's useful
if I say here is this date pattern will
a date within the next hundred years
satisfy that you know we need that for
some basic arithmetic operation it's
like if I say here's my holiday
specification and I want to know the
next time this holiday happens you can
provide holidays specifications that do
not ever resolve and so we need some
sort of formalism to check and say you
know their dates select is an explicit
selector this is not saying given the
timeline so to speak
you know this will slice out just those
moments in the time line for which blah
blah blah right in the the notation we
have currently that we're experimenting
with is the criteria notation which is
named slots that refer to date elements
you know we've looked at having
potentially things like a date object
with an underscore to mean any month or
any year but that syntax is somewhat
limiting and so okay so let's just
understand what we're talking about here
so one thing would be a date object
where we can understand that that's
overly limiting right so we could say
date object of any year um and then you
know like January first of any year yeah
something like that
okay and now your point is if we say
let's try to encode the first Monday of
every month mm-hmm right you've got to
be able to find some way to encode that
um and have you figured out some way to
encode that weekdays get particularly
tricky so the the closest thing that we
have to this in a real application is
scheduling notation so you know the the
cron specification basically has a it's
like format and then have an extra
parameter for the day of week because a
lot of skies around that right you know
we can test and say is the day named
Monday and then we have to do some more
elaborate syntax to say and are there no
prior Monday's within that given month
which that's a mess yeah right or we
have some sort of hanky notation that
says all right we got a bunch of weight
back on was it something some somebody
could adjust things so we don't have
that late
um the okay um so okay so your claim is
hey maybe it's yawn maybe maybe you
should do you have it like a headset or
something where you can actually be
closer to your microphone rather than
being
yes yes sir I can hear just fine um okay
the okay so one set of problems
we're trying to solve all these things
like first month every month
I understand those types of problems
I don't know how related those are -
okay let them explain to me over here
these are things like encoding boy oh
boy oh boy - this is more like or their
to political relations in which we
specify how things work and then we ask
questions which are basically
concurrency questions those can these
things happen at the same time warranty
that this will not happen at the same
time okay so I mean roughly in the in
the temporal logic case what you have is
some some assertion you know assertion
about the world and then you're asking I
guess this is and then you ask questions
based on that that's fair right that is
fair but the major application which we
haven't touched upon yet is also a model
checking where you have your system
model by basically finite state machine
and then you you ask about you then ask
questions in the power logic about this
so if you scroll down a little bit
example yeah that would be a very
minimal example for this use case of
temporal logic so this diagram here it
represents a microwave design and you
can hear that it has a couple of states
and in each state there are positions
that are true at the given state and
then you are interested if basically
certain properties hold so for example
in this case you can be I get it I get
it I get it I get it
so how does this relate to for example
UML diagrams and so on and it took so
this is like a you know this is a
generalized flowchart do you know how to
relate to UML
no not really so I mean typical stuff
for UML right is these kinds of things
people I mean there's industries where I
know what that is so that's some ah as
an example of your mountain diagram
structure diagrams behavior diagrams
that seems relevant yes I believe that
you could basically specify this UML
diagram and ask questions in temporal
logic about this and do model checking
okay but for example in your mouth do we
have examples oh yeah this is um right
so when we make UX designs and things we
end up with those kinds of diagrams and
in particular in um what is it this
thing called x0 which we use for some
the Wii
for UX markups mm-hmm um I'm just trying
to understand how we will actually use
anything both based on this I mean in
other words one of those UML things are
we able to import UML is UML importable
into some format that I mean what does
the UML what is a typical UML diagram
represented as in in the wild did you
understand my question and maybe maybe
we is do we know if Roger is around
today no I think he's busy but I'm the
other person who might um I mean if
we're gonna talk about okay let's see
what does that what does a UML file
format look like nobody no I mean the
gosh UML exchange for my uxf um this is
obscure I mean it great uxf is hardly a
a popular you know there's one Wikipedia
article about it and then at Tim okay
hmm but I know people build these very
big your male models for fur um
particularly supposed to be I don't know
in the defense industry and there's like
that they particularly seem keen on it
um okay um okay so Brian and I live
stream is recommending talking about the
Leslie Lamport TL A+ thing and talking
about showing an example of a FIFO first
and first out and dining philosophers um
[Music]
used for modeling
yeah asynchronous systems like memory
controllers yes and lots of work done on
TL a plus and plus call for writing TL a
programs well okay not stuff I know
about um and see the TLA homepage okay
so this is this is a language click here
to find out what TLA is okay great can
we see a sample program I was from 2012
I'll [ __ ] mistake okay specification
or resource allocator oh my god where
are we gonna go here
alright allocator implementation dot TLA
this is pretty um ok TLA pluses the
newer version alright let's go search
for that
you
what is t la Plus is it hard to use okay
that's pretty much like what we saw that
before
okay assertions assets hey Yan please
could you try to adjust your audio so we
don't keep hearing some weird Clank I
can try that there's not much I can do
I mean it's my phone fine okay okay okay
so this is a whole complicated world of
unclear what do we think the minimal
examples in our kind of serious usage to
this will actually be know things like
when Michael works on food recipes
imagine things like asking whether you
are going to be able to do the whole
thing with a single pan or something
later or you will be able to do two
given things at the same time right okay
so so your your claim is alright so what
are some things that feed into this
there's this T la plus thing there's um
there's whatever I mean there's DFAS and
so on um which we still don't I mean
have a standard representation of
there's things like recipes procedures I
know that people in industry actually
are built finite state machine models
for actual programs in languages like C
or Java and then use model verification
on them yeah I know people been claiming
that for years it happens in all of six
cases in real in real life
in my observation um by our livestream
is is promoting the TLA plus as being
indispensable for modeling complex
asynchronous systems I can believe it it
just looks like a lot of work it looks
it looks complicated and it looks like
the question is what we can contribute
to to you know because it's gotta be a
way of getting your I mean I'll see you
have a protocol what that I can simulate
I can't I can't hear this serious noise
well well then Christopher and then that
implicates you I'm afraid I'm on mute
though oh well that doesn't do that okay
um okay but we're coming back to this my
question is where does one get you know
if there are specifications like for
instance you know I can absolutely
imagine that there are you know I don't
know the checkout in our store for
example has some diagram like this that
represents it right the question is in
what form is that diagram represented
and if we can get that into something or
we can start doing reasoning on it then
it's interesting um but you know how do
we actually do that to get what I'm
saying I mean where does it come from
where do we get that material from so I
think there were two questions one is
how do you represent this and the other
one that was worth doing it's
interesting use cases right yeah ah yes
so in terms of use cases
oh I mean just thinking about this
abstractly in computer science there are
like the for example DFAS are all over
the place and finite state machines are
all over the place yeah but we say no
there is no very obvious representation
of those things where there's boatloads
of them that come to us I mean you know
I've generated lots of DFAS in my life
from cellar
automata which is some completely
bizarre case of them in the case of you
know right now we don't have a
standardized DFA representation in the
language you know what I think that
what's not muted is the person who's
hosting this um okay go ahead yes I have
to think about particular examples I
know that one thing in the industry that
it's just a lot is hardware design yeah
yeah sure Brian is saying that he'd love
to have TL A+ capabilities in
Mathematica the next time he needs to
model an ASIC that is architecting yeah
fair enough but but so the question is
in what form would you have the
specification of that ASIC it's the
thing I'm asking and if it's in very log
I don't know what a6 is specified and
very log or something like that um but
that's a whole nother you know set of
conversions and things one has to
represent there I would think okay very
well we should probably go ahead yeah
yeah the question of sped of the
language for specifying this this is
something we've discussed today with
how's that that we will have to that's
something we'll have to think about
deeper like what is presented here is
obviously are some very very provisional
representation it just takes a graph and
models this as a graph in mathematical
language but as you get like huge
numbers of states and if you want to
model hardware or software we talking
like thousands or even you're not the
problem the problem is how do you ever
get any input that anybody's ever really
going to type in that engages with this
okay because nobody's gonna type in you
know the way you get something like this
it's got to have some there's got to be
some source of this that isn't here
somebody typing this in and the question
is what on earth is that going to be is
there some place where somebody has
already built the specification for
example they've already built it because
they're mocking up the UX right yes so I
presume I mean I don't know much about
hardware design but I presume that
people don't draw
diagrams on the piece of paper so
probably done and very long I would
guess or something like that yes so we'd
have to have some interfaces somewhat
you know I know but but the problem is
there's many other things you have to
represent there I'm saying then enjoy
this this isn't enough it's not really
useful because it's some the fact that
cool that the very loud tutorial looks
like this is a is a what is is there a
more recent version of all of the stuff
um well yes I I don't know very long at
all so it's hard to me to comment on
this model yeah but but this isn't this
isn't a problem we can solve here
because that what is this background
noise it's just driving me nuts does
nobody else hear this
yes
okay the thing I'm look in terms
prioritizing what projects we do a
project that involves the only way
people ever get to this is they typed in
a 50-page you know a huge input that
didn't come from somewhere else I mean
it you know something like you could say
well you know image processing you know
image processing as soon as you've got a
way to get a picture
let's take audio processing okay we
didn't have a way to get audio into the
system audio processing would not be
terribly useful I mean for a long time
we so I'm just trying to ask how would
you get um you know how do you get the
stuff in or if that's not what's going
on how are we using these ideas to deal
with various young generating come on
that um the you know doing simple things
like you know first Monday of every
month so answering to the first question
I don't know the answer of the top of my
head but people in industry claim they
are using this for hardware verification
I am but but then we don't I mean okay
that's because they've got their
hardware specified in some language you
know I don't know these languages like
very log or something okay
it's it's own whole complicated world
it's got it you know it turns into
things that relate to what how system
modeler works it turns into things like
modeling you know how a particular
capacitor works and so on that's a
completely different story from this yes
there is logic stuff that you can then
try and prove things about using these
methods but that's a really thin you
know it's you have to find some way to
extract from that into something useful
here because this representation this
symbolic representation is going to be
nothing like what comes out of the you
know the pure raw you know hardware
design specification they start with my
assumption I mean it you know it's
analogous to this is analogous if you
say it's like hardware stuff I mean okay
great we can look at
we can just say you know if we say
something like this I mean we can look
at you know I'm sorry I'm very I must be
I think it's once some some bizarre I'm
very this background noise it just drive
me nuts I'm able to generated by me I
will try to just mute my microphone when
I'm not speaking yeah you can do that
will help
you
um
okay so you know let's look at an
example here and see what it turns into
because I don't I claimed what what this
turns into normally is systems or
equations but there is also a another
more logical representation of what's
going on
and we have completely the wrong set of
people here to discuss this but but I
mean I didn't think at all we were gonna
go in this direction right I mean I
understand this is a high-end
application of temporal logic but um
let's see
I forgot a sake
that's got that's got not only logic but
also actual
um this is such an ugly browser Wow
really hopefully this will get fixed
soon okay
so I don't know let's try a 8-bit adder
here
it's kind of weird okay digital 8-bit
adder all right let's try this
what does that mean let's copy it is
that just a single block that isn't
adder that's really weird
think you can go inside of it and see
that it has subcomponents how do you get
to the subcomponents
I don't know how you get to them in
Mathematica and system model I think you
like double clicked or something
um yeah I mean here we've got and why
this doesn't autocomplete I have no idea
and that probably should be reported as
a bug somebody could do that that would
be great oh no that's okay um so this
should be generating whatever the
equations are for this but I mean this
is the type of thing where you would
expect this would have if this is all
going to connect together this would
have some Trump or logic representation
presumably
I mean the trouble is that that sister
model is fundamentally about equations
which tell you about the instantaneous
state for all times of a particular
system if that makes sense
whereas temporal logic is telling you I
mean it's sort of a you know a program
is telling you this happens then this
happens then this happens typically well
system modeler is a special case of
temporal logic it's the case where you
just say that such and such a state
implies that such and such a state will
be true in the next moment yeah that's
true
I mean you could think about it that way
I suppose assuming that the equations
have that kind of character of being
initial value equation so this is a big
mess so this didn't work so I know if
you could try and report this also sure
um okay all right all right let's come
back then to
come back to the original so I'm not in
my attempt to orient myself about how
this is going to be used I've been a bit
unsuccessful but let's come back to the
original topic of um okay so you're
saying there's temporal tautology
temporal satisfiable in other words is
there an assignment of are they truth
values what are you assigning to or is
it histories that you're assigning to
you know the P's and Q's of temporal
logic what does it what are the
primitives of temporal logic yes the
analogy of the assignment of truth
values to variables in boolean logic
would be a sequence of worlds in
temporal logic in other words assignment
of true propositions to each state to
each world in the sequence of words that
represents time okay but so clear well
maybe I mean so what you're saying is
there's a proposition P it's raining for
example and instead of there being you
know normally we would have something
where we say um you know okay so we're
talking about what the variables are
here so I mean normally we would just
say P is a proposition that means you
know it is raining but what you're
saying in temporal logic is that it
means that P is a whole family of
statements it's like oh not really
rather that we have a sequence of worlds
and it can be true in some of them and
false in others whereas in boolean logic
peace like always true please please
just true or false but in Marathi but I
mean so a naive thing would be to say we
have it I mean okay so this is another
place where this temporal logic is
relevant okay which which should have
been brought up here is in time series
because in a time series for example we
just had this issue what the heck was
the issue it just had this issue with
the time series so here's the point by
the time series normally with the time
series you say um you know
you know law is the value at time X time
T right but sometimes what you want to
do is you want to say that value will
continue until such and such a thing
happens so we just had this was this for
oh I remember it was we were looking at
historical countries right and we're
asking the question in a if you have a
historical country and we know that in
18:47 the country was invaded or
something the polygon we have so this is
this the very practical example the
polygon from 1830 to 1847 we know the
polygon in 1830 and we want that polygon
to continue to be in effect until the
event happens in 1847
so what I'm saying I think you could
technically do that with a time series
of interpolation order arrow zero but
time series like I remember I did this I
was doing this exact thing where I was
representing historical countries and at
one point I tried representing in with
time series with interpolation order 0
which worked and which did that although
it had some other very weird funky
consequences so I think there's things
like left hold and right hold and things
like this where you're saying the things
should be equal to what it was at the
beginning of the period and such like
where do you mean in this temporal logic
a mean time series in time series
because I'm trying to understand what is
the relationship between but that that's
kind of what okay I at least left hold
is basically what you're saying yes
that's correct
is the default and otherwise when you
write holes just by shifting everything
over yeah that's true I'm putting one
thing at time negative infinity which
I'm pretty sure you
fair enough yeah I mean Brian our
livestream is pointing out that a
temporal logic specification could be
converted into a controller object would
be supercool but that's then that's a
whole different I mean you know if we
compare that again we're looking at
other comparables and we've got our
microcontroller kit so let's let's
understand relationship I'm sorry I'm
still trying to oh that's disappointing
where is the microcontroller kit
did I spell something wrong that's
really weird isn't this in the
documentation now I
it hasn't been committed
that's really weird I knew it's another
issue cast
what is going on here something is very
wrong
this is
ah okay so I had I misspelled
microcontroller although the fact that
our spelling corrector can't deal with
that is pathetic
that generates that there two issues
there one was a stupid thing of the
spell corrector for them so that maybe
getting fixed for other reasons okay so
let's just try to understand this what
is the relationship boy there's so much
stuff I don't know a state-space model
all this transfer function model what is
the relationship with any of this stuff
to
I mean these are all given a continuous
input this is the continuous output
that's produced these are not these
things that say there are discrete
events that lead to other events I think
that this is a model so you could
imagine I suppose something where you
have a specification in your you know of
us essentially something like a state
transition diagram or this piece of
temporal logic and then you could
imagine
I suppose although it seems exotic to
figure out how to connect everything up
to say there's gonna be certain inputs
that you connect things to boy
yeah I mean I have no idea whether you
can actually write hmm okay
look I think I'm again I'm still a bit
disoriented but this is the first time
we've talked about temporal logic so I
would say that the other things that
were discussing were more related to
differential equations you know events
that happened as a given time things
like that well in temporal logic here we
are we are discussing more like
relations of things that we don't know
exactly when they happen but we know
that one happens before the other one
you know and so we are interested in
knowing whether they will know I mean it
literally
right so clearly for kind of common
sense reasoning type stuff for whatever
good that is this stuff is useful and
having I mean you know what do we know
about the spatial analog of this you
know such and such as inside such and
such such and such as on top of such and
such and so on
do we know anything about but there must
be a similar I know there is a similar
kind of logic for special purposes this
is one dimensional so the only thing I
can relate is is is Allan algebra of of
intervals
okay well that's a whole nother issue
right I mean in in you know is one
interval greater than the other another
interval you know do they overlap but so
what is the element of that in temporal
logic if I if I can define an interval
of touch okay how do i define an
interval of time here but there's no
such thing as an interval but you can
say this happens until the other one so
you know that it will be before so it's
more like relations rather than actual
numbers yes I mean for us
you know again to make to be practical
here okay so okay let's just look again
at some I mean so this is you know dates
etc right so we might have a date
interval here and then you know we might
not want to ask the question what's the
analog of this I'm still trying to mmm
you know there's a simple question of is
this date interval you know is this date
interval completely before what what's
the analog of this continues to be true
up until bla bla bla
there must be some analog of that is the
statement of all completely before some
other data interval perhaps the analogy
with first of their logic John could be
useful here because this is a bit like
first order logic together with some
inequalities well yes that's true but it
depends what you mean by date interval
do you mean here a concrete interval of
time and time here as a sequence or as a
continuous model of time
I might be granular if we have
granularity in that but I would say it
was some but what's your point I mean
that the thing I'm trying to do is is to
say is this interval complete okay so
for example um does interval to start
before the end of interval one how would
we say that and is that is this is this
kind of representation of is that useful
to this I know that people mix interval
algebra with with temporal logic but I
think we would need more extent more
extended version than the standard LTL
for example we would need also a a way
to referring to the past so if you are
in some point and you want to talk about
the interval you want also to talk about
moments before this point and this is
possible as well okay I'm trying and
trying to understand in practice okay if
we implement all this stuff right yeah
how are people going to use it and I'm
trying to understand these types of
things like you know date intervals were
about to have and I think Dayton tolls
we clearly know a useful because there's
things were and so so so I good so I
initially focused on the applications
that I knew are most used in the Indian
Open I don't believe this industry
applications thing okay that the problem
is something like circuit design there's
a giant stack of technology used for
that it's you know we don't have most of
what's there not our business you know
not the right thing to focus on right
the the case that's interesting to us is
the case where the technology of
temporal logic intersects with things
that often will never have been done
before that have run you know that we've
run into through for example the fact
that we have a large knowledge base the
fact that um you know we represent
things like historical countries which
are not things that you know all we all
we represent
eating things like gum I don't know
complicated date specifications that are
relevant
you know finance computations things
like this these things were where you
know rather than trying to emulate some
giant stack of stuff about you know
circuit you know verification which I
just don't think I mean you know in the
case of boolean algebra for example we
have fine state-of-the-art stuff for
doing things like satisfiability and
boolean algebra and that is occasionally
you know very useful to people but I you
know it's not going to be something in
order to use it to do circuit stuff you
have to have a big stack of other things
that's not really our business um so
mm-hmm
okay so I mean in you know what I had
thought with temporal logic was and I
still think that for a lot of the things
we want to do for example the things I
want to do eventually with the whole
symbolic discourse language business
where you can take you know everyday
statements
you know about things let's say in
English and write them in a more formal
way this can be useful for that so long
as it's a decent model so cautionary
tale okay yes back in the day people
thought propositional logic and then
predicate logic would be a rote way of
representing all human knowledge turned
out to be a pretty stupid idea
you know in other words there's I mean
the hot you know you can start writing
50,000 predicate logic statements about
the world and that's turned out nobody
has found that terribly useful it's just
not a very good representation um
and um yeah but Brian on our live stream
is pointing out Microsoft Madam's amused
temporal logic to validate the design of
the database systems I don't doubt it
and similarly I mean I don't doubt it
there's there's no question that I mean
we could use it to do things with
validating UX designs right if we could
only get those UX designs into a form
that we could compute with in some
reasonable way right because and I'm and
then we have to think about it let's say
it was a UX design for a store checkout
okay what is the native form of that UX
design so eventually that that store
checkout is going to turn into random
web code okay but but you know see again
we have the wrong people on this call
but that this may be a bit like graph
theory in the sense that people will
have to find their ways into
constructing the graph and here we have
a directed graph then we can reason
about is it possible to find parts for
which this thing happens or this
property that will happen for all the
direct paths the graph right I think
that's a good analogy right I mean it's
it's like you can take okay so okay so
let's just say um you know getting
whatever they might be called you know
temporal specifications or something
which are essentially flow charts etc
right so so this ETL version it's just
generic computations with trace with
directories
right by me okay so to give an example
right so this is a tool at our UX design
folks sometimes use okay so conditional
flow what oh my gosh
you can't even click on this wow that's
weird
okay so there we go so that's a typical
I mean the UX group often produces these
unbelievably complicated diagrams which
I can't understand
but that's that's what they're doing is
something like that okay um
okay so my question is so I mean to me
this is exactly the type of thing you're
talking about ah yes I think that would
be directly applicable to this I mean
but the poem else but right right right
but the problem is the way people
normally do it it was the same with like
like Vizio is another example I think of
a thing it has a little bit less
semantics than this that where you know
there's a specification and it's
represented in this graph but then I
take your point that you know if we can
ever get the graph out as a graph
okay so let's understand the analog to
the graph okay so we could have a graph
whose state's you know we'll have some
random graph I also like to focus so
much on specifying the transition system
as a graph I mean in terms of just how
we specify your transition system we can
have much more flexibility
I understand that but but I'm saying
there's a source of boatloads of these
things if you can get out of something
like this a graph all right I mean this
thing will eventually be some labeled
graph where there is semantics like
those are probably conditionals right
yes remember my flowcharts right so the
question is if there is some reasonable
way but so so here we don't have any
such thing our graph is just a graph the
fact that the output of you know that
that that node has four you know valence
four is irrelevant to the it's just a
graph it just says hi I'm connected to
these other nodes it has no semantics we
need some labeling on this graph yeah
sure but I mean so if we have a directed
graph we have one so I mean I think
again this is this is you know look
we've got you know we've got the concept
of a directed graph um we've got the you
know beyond the directed graph we've got
sort of a finite state machine I guess
beyond that we've got things like Petri
Nets I think and what about this will
shout at an Origin Busia automata are
basically used for i/o I don't think
they are relevant here there are
something that there are kind of
automata that represent temporal formula
so these things oh this
what's that that's a certain kind of an
errata that recognizes infinite
languages yes I remember that right I
think it's a dear
without yes no sorry it's yeah without
yes mm-hmm okay um okay but imagine that
we had some UX specification then what
would we want to you know that UX
specification looks like a graph and but
somehow I mean gosh see we could
represent a graph okay so given a graph
we could say they're a bunch of
relations
Rell a be rel you know bc rel ad those
kinds of things right that is a way to
represent a graph that make sense
alternatively we can just say to this we
can just say instead of rel we call that
rule and then that whole thing is a
graph and sure enough it will be a graph
a very exciting graph but it's a graph
right indeed and so what you're saying
is what what are the nodes I mean in
your thing you're I'm confused about
what in a diagram like this your
statement P for example where it says
always P or something what relationship
does that P have two things in this
graph mm-hmm
okay so at each node in the graph we
have to specify what is true in this
state so each each node will represent
some state and some things are true in
this state well one thing that can be
true is the name of the state it can
like be state can be uniquely identified
by the proposition that says it is the
state of this name but so what I'm
saying about temporal logic is we pick
some node that we start from and we say
that something holds on all possible
paths from this node okay so for example
I say that if I start from this node
then
whatever path I take until something hop
and til I get to some state something
will be true okay let me give an example
okay we'll talk about a store checkout
it better be true of a store checkout
that you can eventually checkout
yes it's very true right otherwise it's
not a good business proposition so to
speak yeah I agree
the um it might also you might also want
a property that says you can always
cancel any transaction until you check
out okay yes yes so now the question
would be um and by the way another thing
obviously okay so let me give another
example of temporal logic that I can
imagine which maybe is similar what
Brian was talking about as soon as we
start doing not just reading relational
database stuff but also writing
relational database stuff there is the
question of whether you respect you know
atomicity and all this kind of thing
properly and one could certainly imagine
representing that in terms of this you
know first you do this you write this
piece of data you do that and you say
will you ever be able to get into a
situation where you can corrupt the data
I think that's a similar kind of problem
yes angry but the thing that I'm having
a hard time with is you know how does
one get from the piece of code that
represents all that stuff to something
that you can actually work with in
temporal logic
I mean the trouble is okay let me give
an example so we are just about at the
point so we can derive a call graph for
you know from a bunch of Wolfram
language code we're not the world's
easiest language to derive a call graph
from because obviously we have dynamic
code in things but let's assume that we
we do have stuff to ingest like large C
programs and derive their call graphs so
there we get a nice graph from the wild
and so we might be able to ask a
question like is there piece of code
dead
in the sense that it can't be reached
from any place that is an exterior node
I think that what one thing that will be
very useful to check is for example if
you have some concurrent software is
there a deadlock like this be wonderful
but the question is in what do you
represent this is what you know I'm sure
this TL A+ thing is a way of
specifically representing that I I
expect I mean I you know naive plus
thought would be that in some language
like Erlang that there would be some way
of taking I don't know taking Erlang
code and running some verify that
determines whether whether you can have
deadlock hey Christopher do you know for
these languages or something like go or
something is that something people
routinely do or as the language
structured so can never happen wait
sorry is what something at the full
routine they do check for deadlock in a
go program I'm not sure that I have to
think about whether you can actually get
deadlock like if there so maybe designed
so you can't get deadlock
I obviously by if by deadlock you just
mean that it it stops I mean of course
because it's Turing complete that could
happen they could not halt but I mean if
you mean deadlock is in why why is
waiting for X and so the rounds I'm
pretty sure that can't happen because
each goat like in the case of go right
because that's sort of the most relevant
case here each routine can only I mean
well actually no you could yes you could
easily make a situation like that but I
mean would be kind of it would be kind
of trivial like you could just tell one
go routine wait for something on this
channel and another go routine wait for
something on some other channel and just
nobody writes to the IDA channel they'll
just sit there forever
right Phil on our livestream points out
the temporal logic and the ask function
might be an interesting combination
automatic website flow yeah that that's
an interesting idea that something like
ask can it get itself into a so I mean I
I'm understanding why this is
potentially useful the part that I'm
having a hard time whether I'm trying to
you know grapple with is you know I
think your analogy with graphs is a good
one that many things turn into graphs
and it is varying amounts of work to
turn them into graphs and then you know
and then and then do computations on
them and but so you know places that you
might get stuff from ah it was I'm
making a list of this yeah I mean it
places you might get stuff um I guess
would be you know okay so sources might
be things like UX designs um you know I
suppose
kinds of database slash concurrent code
but you know you have to have a
representation of that code what about
all these things with you know I mean
okay things like the few textures and
mutexes of this world that the how are
those represented what is the abstract
representation of those things
hey Christopher do you know that I mean
in other words people write them in
specific languages but is there some
more abstract representation maybe
that's this this TLA thing as a way of
doing that I mean that there is an
overarching I mean between languages
there is an overarching abstract idea of
a mutex that's what you mean
no but I'm asking if you are to
abstractly represent without a specific
mutex that does a specific thing yeah
you're to represent the idea of a mutex
that presumably what what is can you say
like in temporal logic language what a
mutex is yeah I think so okay so let's
you need a variable that represents
whether the mutex is locked so okay it's
like L so I think you would just say
something like well okay okay you
basically need to say that if L is so
okay L implies that L implies that the
state of the mute of the variable right
now so let's call it a that that a imply
that the if the state of a is something
that it had the same state later so I
think you could say L implies I don't
know how we representing this but L
implies that a by conditional next
moment is a I'm not sure if that's
entirely right with the next moment
thing but something like that and you
need to make sure the parentheses I
don't know what the precedence is if you
care okay well so wait a minute so it's
saying if it's locked if it's locked
then a will not change between now and
the next moment if it's not locked then
all bets are off
okay but so what is that B okay so what
else is there to say about it
I mean I think that's that's it I mean
some other recessions like the lock will
eventually be I mean in you know
eventually there won't be a lock you
don't know that it could be locked
forever it could it could be locked
forever it could never lock that's
that's that's just depends on how you
use it
I understand but for example we have a
practical problem okay so this is a
practical issue with cloud objects okay
we are considering having something
where you can do critical whatever
they're called these some places where
you can do updates oh gosh what is this
called um you know wait where you
guarantee that you don't corrupt the
thing a critical section or something
the thing where where you say okay so
but we want we don't want the lock to
last forever because if the lock lost
forever
you've just frozen your file system well
you need to do other analysis on what
sets the variable L to know whether L
will at some point B I know what you
want might want to have an assertion
that says eventually L will not be
locked over that's the point you're
trying to figure out if L will
eventually be not locked so you you
can't have that as an assertion if
that's what you're trying to check so
sorry presumably you want to you need to
okay so my guess is that we want the
locks to in practice and in the cloud
object store we want the locks to decay
right but I suspect that a good example
of a temporal logic use case is to make
sure that when the lock is removed
through timeouts that nothing terrible
happens at that moment like or something
bad could I don't know if you want it to
lock bite like unlocked by taina unless
it's it's literally just someone who's
making a change and they timeout because
their connection is bad no no no I mean
I mean the thing was locked and you're
three days later and you're like like if
it's three days later and it's still
locked there's a very fundamental bug
going on no no but but think about this
the code somebody writes says start the
critical section okay then for some
reason because of that code well I guess
I guess you're saying it's an exogenous
effect because that
code fails to complete yeah and you have
to know that I mean and and right I mean
and I write and the point is if that
code fails to complete for crashes and
of course you should take off the lock
but I mean the thing is is that the only
way you'd know that is by doing analysis
of the other parts of the club but the
statement if the code crashes you take
off the lock it's already something that
can be written in this more formal way
yeah sure I mean passing is like like
the example Yann had earlier of you know
of not living forever and so on once a
piece of code crashes it can't
uncrashable some logic okay so I get the
point there if you want if you want an
example of the case where you could
reason something about this mutex so
suppose that the variable that you're
storing in a mutex is is another mutex
it's like the lock properties right then
we could show that if the first mutex
okay if the outside new Texas is locked
and the inside mutex is it some point
ever locked then the inside mutex cannot
unlock until the outside mutex unlocks
right that's a random thing that you
could derive you know I'm not sure how
useful that is but right okay so look
we're going to run out of time in just
moments here unfortunately this was I
mean this was a good first introduction
and I think I mean so in what you've
done
yawn so let me just understand what you
actually done so you've got it so that
with those primitives you can do various
kinds of reasoning is that correct yes
in particular we can do tautology
checking satisfiability checking and
model checking for finite state machines
this satisfiability checking not is it
np-complete satisfiability checking here
is pspace I believe for LTL which means
that it's X time
okay okay cuz it's tqb f for whatever
it's similar to that what I mean yeah
it's in polynomial space so less things
whether it's yeah okay so it's some
pspace-complete creature maybe yes um
okay but but so it doesn't mean in
practice one can't do it I mean like
bullet satisfiability checking you know
we have a pretty good satisfiability
checker even though in principle
satisfiability you know well one doesn't
know how long it will really take but
but it's some okay the good thing is
that model checking for CTL is
polynomial time I'm not surprised
because there's a linear you know
there's some kind of linear sequence in
the picture um all right listen we
should wrap this up here you know next
step I really think we got to understand
a little bit more about where you get I
mean you know when we did the graphs for
example we had a pretty good
understanding of where you know we have
a nice simple representation for graphs
they're pretty easy to type in here one
of the things that bothers me is that
you know you're having to well you could
argue the same thing as true for boolean
expressions that that you have to invent
some symbol
yeah
I guess one difference between graphs
and this is that in graphs there are
applications of graphs where every node
means something but there also plenty of
applications of graphs where just you
get nodes by the boatload
and similarly with boolean expressions
there are applications of boolean
expressions where you get essentially
variables that are just abstract
variables in this case I'm not seeing
serious applications where that's the
case is that a first statement I'm not
saying if I got the point
we've boolean algebra here could you
give an example of such application well
I'm saying that yeah I mean I can I can
go ahead and you know I can say boolean
function
you know 145 comma 3 ok that's just some
random boolean function I'm not having
to discuss the fact that the first
variable means whether the microwave
oven is on the second variable means
whether its door is open those kinds of
things they're just abstract it's just
abstract arguments to you know abstract
you know it's an abstract thing so to
speak you also could have like abstract
arguments no I understand but so is it
useful I mean like for example with
boolean functions like cellular automata
would be a good application of this well
one very loose idea that they have is
maybe that could be useful in
computational contracts for example
that's what I do
ok yeah that is a
that's an idea that should have been in
the very beginning of this discussion
sorry sorry say it before but I wanted
to finish first on this ultimate happy
yeah you're right that's a good
application I mean that that that's a
good case I mean so for example you know
writing you know a no double spend type
condition for instance alright we have
run out of time but but finally in the
last moment we've understood what the
real okay all right I'm I'm much more
sold on it with the site with that with
that point the um right okay we should
wrap it up here then so we'll continue
and we will will we should pick this up
again fairly soon because I think you've
been actively working on this we don't
want you going off in sort of the wrong
direction here um we're asking when the
next live stream will be and I'm not
sure what the answer that is it's
definitely going to be after Christmas
um that's my theory but I'm not quite
sure when um all right well thanks for
thank thank you yawn thank you everybody
here thank you people on the livestream
bunch of good and interesting comments
and to be continued thank you okay